Tina Seelig: I'm Tina Seelig, and I play two
roles here today.
First, I am the host normally.
But today, I am also the speaker.
So I'm going to give you a little bit of my
background so you know actually who am I besides
the person who usually introduces our other
guests.
I am the executive director of the Stanford
Technology Ventures Program, and along with
my wonderful colleagues Tom Byers and Kathy
Eisenhardt -- who are the faculty directors
-- we run the Stanford Technology Ventures
Program.
And we spent all out of our efforts thinking
about research and teaching and outreach efforts
all related to high-tech entrepreneurship.
My background is a little bit unusual.
I actually did my Ph.D. over at the med school.
I did my Ph.D.
in neuroscience, and after that I've done
a bunch of different things.
I was a management consultant, I was a multimedia
producer, I worked at Compac.
I started a company.
And I also have written a whole bunch of books.
And this talk is about the most recent book
I wrote called, "What I wish I knew when I
was 20.”
Now, there's an interesting story behind this
talk, because I actually gave a talk by the
same name three years ago right here.
At that point, this talk was extremely raw.
It was brand new.
It was just the beginning of some ideas.
But what happened is, the talk ended up really
getting some traction.
And a year ago -- almost exactly a year ago
-- I was asked by HarperCollins to turn this
talk into a book.
And so, over the last year, I spent a lot
of time digging into these concepts and came
up with a bunch of really new and interesting
stories and, in fact, changed my point of
view on some of these ideas.
So I'm going to tell you a little bit about
what's inside this book and invite you at
the end to ask whatever questions you might
have.
Okay. So, as part of my role at STVP, I have
the incredible honor of teaching a course
on Creativity and Innovation.
In fact, I see some of my students in the
room.
And the entire overarching theme of this class
is that "All problems are opportunities.”
The bigger the problem, the bigger the opportunity.
In fact, anyone in my class would probably
be able to recite that in their sleep, right?
Any problem is an opportunity.
The bigger the problem, the bigger the opportunity.
And what I do is, I give students problems.
They start out as really small problems, and
over the course of the quarter, they get bigger
and bigger and bigger, until finally, they
just get extremely comfortable taking on challenges
and looking at them through the lens of possibilities.
Now, don't just listen to me.
I mean, Why should you listen to me telling
you that problems are opportunities?
This is something that is embraced by the
entire venture capital community and the whole
entrepreneurial community.
In fact, I'm going to play you a videoclip
that I play all the time, and it's one of
my favorites.
It's by Vinod Khosla.
Do you guys know who Vinod Khosla is?
Who is he? Founder of Sun Microsystems, successful
venture capitalist.
And this is a 27-second-long clip where he
talks about problems as opportunities.
Vinod Khosla: One thing I would say is, "Find
a big problem.
To me any big problem is a big opportunity.”
Because if you think about it, no problem,
no solution, no company.
It's very simple.
Every big problem is a big opportunity.
If you don't have a big problem, you don't
have a big opportunity.
Nobody will pay you to solve a nonproblem.
Tina Seelig: In fact, I see that was a talk
where Tom Byers, my colleague, was introducing
him, interviewing him.
And it's a clip that we play in all of our
classes.
Because this is the essence, the core of entrepreneurship.
So how do you teach this?
How do you teach people to turn problems into
opportunities and look at the world as 'opportunity
rich'?
Is it like this? Is this what you do?
You line people up in rows and columns, right?
In fact, it kind of looks like this room right
here.
Everyone lined up in rows and columns, the
chairs bolted to the floor, God forbid, you
know, you actually talk to anyone else or
move around.
Looks like everyone's taking a multiple choice
test where they're filling out one right answer
to every question, filling it out with a number
two pencil.
Is that how you teach creativity?
I don't think so.
This is the way you teach creativity.
You get people out of their comfort zone.
You get them jumping off of perfectly good
cliffs.
You get them to feel it in their gut.
It's not necessarily a completely intellectual
experience.
You need to be able to take risks, to do things
you haven't done before, to take on problems
no one knows the answer to.
So what I'm going to do is, tell you about
some of the things that we do in our classes
to help people have this experience.
So a few years ago I was -- the D school -- the
Design School at Stanford was just starting
off.
And there was the first year.
There was a boot camp class.
There was a whole cast of thousands of people
teaching the class.
And I was asked to teach one week that focused
on entrepreneurship.
"Tina will you teach one week that gets folks
understanding the general principles and the
ideas of entrepreneurial thinking?”
So I thought, "What can I do?”
So what I did is, I gave the students, every
team, an envelope.
And in that envelope was seed funding.
How many of you know this story?
Okay. We're going to cut to the chase in a
second and go on to the next stories.
But this one is the first assignment I gave.
They had an envelope, and in that envelope
was seed-funding.
They had four or five days to plan as long
as they wanted, but as soon as they opened
that envelope, they had two hours to make
as much money as possible.
Now, for those people who don't know this.
Folks who don't know this story, How much
money do you think I gave them?
Any guesses?
>> $500.
Tina Seelig: $500. Anyone else?
>> Five dollars.
Tina Seelig: Five dollars. I bet you know
this story. Okay?
I know you know this story.
So, okay, let's cut to the chase here.
I gave them five dollars and two hours to
make as much money as possible.
So what would you do if you were given this
challenge? What would you do?
Think about it.
Does anyone have any ideas? Any thoughts?
Organize a party. Invite everyone.
Are you going to basically charge people?
Absolutely.
You're going to charge people to come to your
party.
Love that idea. Great. I'd love to come.
How much are you going to charge people?
>> Ten dollars.
Tina Seelig: Ten dollars? And how much is
the party going to cost?
>> About $50.
Tina Seelig: So you only need five people
to break even.
Okay, good. Anyone else? Another idea?
What you might do with five dollars and two
hours?
First of all, you guys get gold stars, because
usually when I ask that question, the first
thing anyone ever says is, "Go to Las Vegas,"
or "Buy a lottery ticket."
>> [Laughter]
Tina Seelig: Really. They feel like, "Well,
you know, I should take a really high risk
for earning a big reward.”
Of course, we all know that the high likelihood
is that you're going to walk away with nothing.
Well, let me tell you the clue.
The teams that made the most money didn't
use the five dollars at all.
They realized that the five dollars was actually
a limitation.
They realized that that framed the problem
way too tightly, and that if they looked at
the skills they had and the opportunities
around them, that was worth a lot more.
So with that in mind, what do you think you
would do?
Any thoughts?
Okay. Since you're being shy, I'm going to
tell you.
I'm going to give you a couple of examples.
One team set up a stand in the middle of the
Student Union here at Stanford in front of
Tresidder.
And they just said -- they put up a little
sign that said, "We will measure your bicycle
tire pressure for free, but if you need air
in the tires, we will charge you a dollar.”
Pretty cool?
Well, first they thought they were taking
advantage of their fellow classmates, because
people could go around the corner and easily
get their bike tires pumped up for free.
But you know what?
They realized halfway through the two hours
that people were incredibly appreciative.
And so, what they did is, they stopped asking
for a dollar.
And halfway through, they asked for donations
instead.
And you know what happened?
People paid them much more.
And they walked away at the end of two hours
with a couple hundred dollars.
Pretty cool?
Now, there was some interest things that fell
out of this experiment.
First of all, they realized that iterating
along the way -- experimenting was incredibly
valuable.
They could have stayed in their dorm room,
written a business plan, and they never would
have learned the fact, all of these things
they learned along the way.
You know, that by asking for donations, they
actually made more.
So by rapidly prototyping, experimenting,
and you know, trying things out along the
way, they actually learned a tremendous number
of things.
Another team did something equally clever.
They realized that, in Palo Alto -- I'm sure
all of you know this as well -- there were
really long lines at restaurants on Saturday
night.
In fact, sometimes it's an hour-and-a-half
wait to get a table at the most popular restaurants.
So what they did is they split up, and they
made reservations at all the most popular
restaurants.
And as those times came up, they sold the
reservations.
Yeah, question?
>> [inaudible]
Tina Seelig: Yeah. Well, they realized they
were basically scalping restaurant reservations.
And so, you know, people with a screaming,
hungry kid -- for any of you who know what
that's like -- they're like, "Of course, I'll
pay $20 to skip in front of you in line.
I've got to feed my baby.”
So here was another thing.
Again, they learned some really cool things
along the way.
First, the women were much better at selling
the reservations.
People trusted them more. Go figure.
Okay. So the guys ran around making reservations;
the women sold them.
But here was another really important insight.
They realized this worked best in the restaurants
that use those buzzers that tell you when
their time comes up, because there was something
very tangible they could sell.
So it's kind of like a reverse hand grenade,
"Here it's going to go off in five minutes.
Take it.” Okay?
The other thing that happened as a result
of that is, they traded the buzzers.
Now, they had now traded up to a later reservation.
Pretty cool?
So they realized -- these students walked
away with a huge insight and that is, they
should never look around and say, "I don't
have any money in my pockets.”
Because there were opportunities everywhere
just waiting to be solved, whether it was
tires that needed to get filled up or whether
it was restaurant reservations.
But, the team that made the most money challenged
all of the assumptions.
They broke all the rules and they continue
to open the frame of the problem beyond anything
that I imagined.
They realized the most valuable thing they
had was not the five dollars and was not the
two hours.
They realized the most valuable thing they
had was their three-minute presentation time,
which they sold to a company that wanted to
recruit those students.
Pretty cool?
So I thought they're onto something. This
was so great.
This was a mind-blowing, life-changing experience
for the students in this class.
And again, we pushed them off of that cliff
and gave them a problem without any right
answers.
In fact, the answers they came up with were
much better than anything I could have put
on the answer key, right?
But I had one problem after I gave this assignment.
And it was really preying on my mind.
And that problem was that I felt that I was
communicating that value was measured in terms
of making money.
And we all know that that's not the case,
right?
That value is created in so many different
ways besides, you know, cold hard cash.
So the next quarter in my creativity class,
I decided to give this assignment again, but
instead of giving the students five dollars,
I gave them a handful of paper clips.
Ten paper clips. And four hours.
I told them, "You now have one week.
You have ten paper clips and four hours to
create as much value as possible.
Somehow you've got to use these paper clips.”
And I was inspired by the guy who started
with the one red paper clip and traded to
a house.
You guys know the story?
How many people do not know the story of the
one red paper clip? Okay.
This was a guy a few years ago who basically
said, "I really, really, really want a house,
and all I have is one red paper clip.”
So he set up a blog and decided to trade the
paper clip up until he had a house.
And he did it.
He started with a paper clip.
He traded it for a pen and the pen for a doorknob
and the doorknob for this and that and this
and that.
And over the course of a year, he ended up
with a house.
Now, I believe the house was like in Saskatchewan,
but it still was a house, okay?
So I thought I was being very generous giving
these students ten paper clips.
So, okay, folks.
What would you do with ten paper clips -- four
hours, ten paper clips?
Any thoughts?
>> Pick some locks.
Tina Seelig: Pick some locks.
Okay, let's cut to the chase, because I'm
going to show you what one of the teams did.
Is there some way for us to lower the lights
a little bit?
Is that something I should have asked at all?
What's that? Okay.
Let's show it, and see if it works.
>> [music]
>> Bad boys. What you want, what you want,
what you want to do.
When the servicemen come for you.
Tell me what you want to do, what you going
to do.
Tell. Bad boys, bad boys, what you going to
do?
What you going to do when they come for you?
Bad boys, bad boys, what you going to do?
When you were eight and you had bad traits,
you go to school and learn the golden rule.
So why are you acting like a bloody fool if
you get.
Tina Seelig: Okay, at this point -- I kid
you not -- I was lying on the floor hyperventilating.
I thought I really did love that job, okay?
Because I am fired now.
I mean, I am out of here.
There is no way I'm talking my way out of
this one.
The students -- I said, "How did you do this?
What did you do?”
They said, "You know, it was a fraternity
party, things get stolen all the time.
No one even noticed.”
Then they said, "Just kidding.”
So what they actually did is, they took the
ten paper clips and they traded them for some
posterboard.
And they made a sign that said, "Stanford
students for sale.
Buy one, get two free.” Okay?
And they went to the Stanford Shopping Center
and they sat in the middle of the shopping
center with their sign.
And they started asking people, "What can
we do for you?" Just like this fellow suggested,
What can I do for you?
You guys are too creative here, you know.
So they -- first people asked them, Well can
you carry my bags to my car?
Can you take out the recycling? But eventually,
they learned how to sell themselves a little
better.
They realized they were engineering students.
They had a lot more skills than carrying bags
and taking out recycling.
One guy asked them if they could, you know,
design a transreceiver for him.
And they said, "Yes, we could, but probably
take a little more than four hours.”
So a woman came up -- a business exec -- and
she said, "Boy, you're in a course on creativity.
I've got a business problem I'm really struggling
with at work.
Would you mind coming to my office and leading
a brainstorming session with my team?”
They said, "No problem. We know how to do
this.”
And so, they went to her office; they led
a brainstorming session for a couple of hours.
She was so delighted with the outcome, she
paid them in three computer monitors that
she didn't need. Pretty cool?
So they arrived in class with three computer
monitors starting with ten paper clips.
The other teams did things that were equally
inventive.
And I don't have all the videos there to show
you.
But I want to tell you, this was the start
of something very big.
Because that what happened is, I got a call
from the Kauffman Foundation.
Many of you might have heard of them.
They are the big, entrepreneurship foundation
there in Kansas City.
And they decided about three years ago to
launch a National Entrepreneurship Week.
And they called me and said, "Tina would you
take the lead at Stanford in making this happen?”
I said, "No problem.”
So I called up my friends, you know, e-mailed
my friends across campus who were in the business
school and the law school and the med school
and the engineering school all over and said,
"We're going to put together this week.”
So we did this sort of open-source week where
everybody took a day to do something.
And we had talks, and lectures and workshops
and etc. etc.
But it was preying on my mind, that guy jumping
off that cliff, and I said, "You know what?
We can't have an entrepreneurship week unless
we do.”
So came up with the idea of using this concept
as a cross-campus activity.
And this time gave the students one pack of
Post-it Notes. Okay?
A hundred, 3 x 3 Post-its, and the idea is
they had all week during Entrepreneurship
Week when we unveiled this object the first
day -- this challenge.
And they had one week to create as much value
as possible using Post-it Notes.
Well, I told the Kauffman Foundation.
They got so excited.
They said, "Boy, can we roll this out around
the country?”
And I said, "Let's not stop there.
Let's roll it out around the world.
I run conferences all over the planet and
one e-mail, I was able to invite colleagues
and their students to participate in this
challenge.
So we had thousands of students around the
world creating as much value as they could
with Post-it Notes.
And the idea was, they could measure value
in any way they wanted.
So what would you do? You guys are now up
to speed.
You've done the five dollars.
You've done the paper clips.
What would you do with Post-it Notes?
What's that? A treasure hunt.
You could use an integrated treasure hunt.
Great idea.
Any other thoughts? Yep, back there.
You could put artwork on it.
We could have poetry on it. Terrific.
Let me play you a videoclip, a short clip
from one of the teams, and you tell me what
kind of value was created by this team?
>> [rapid music]
Tina Seelig: Pretty cool.
What kind of value was created? What's that?
Information and saving energy, right? So this
was put on YouTube and thousands of people
watched this video.
I know that I, for one -- when I ended up
leaving town to go away for Spring break,
I unplugged all the appliances -- all the
equipment -- in my office.
So they ended up having a really, big impact
using Post-it Notes for a sort of public service
announcement. Pretty cool?
So I could spend the entire talk just showing
you video clips of what happened with Post-its,
because they were really remarkable.
And the teams did things.
They created collaborative music projects.
They created a company called Gumball Capital
that actually turned into a real company raising
money.
They got solicitations for money to raise
it for Kiva.
But I want to move on, because again, this
took on a life of its own.
The next year, we decided to do this again.
And I wanted to come up with a challenge that
was somewhat different, because everyone had
been thinking about Post-it Notes all year,
and I really wanted to stretch everyone's
imagination -- give them something that might
be even a little harder.
So the next year -- here we were up in Memorial
Auditorium -- the whole place is packed.
John Hennessy, the president of Stanford,
introduces the week, welcomes everyone.
I get up there and reveal the next challenge
-- the next object -- and the air got sucked
out of the room.
Because they now had to create value with
a rubberband.
I wanted to stretch their imagination.
And they could use as many rubberbands as
they wanted -- as many colors, as many sizes,
as many as they wanted.
What would you guys do if you were given this
challenge?
Any thoughts?
Want me to show you one?
Get your mind thinking? Okay.
Let me show you.
This was actually some students from my class.
I'm very proud of them.
You tell me at the end what you think.
>> Tired of bikes gobbling up your laces?
Troublesome doorways?
Loose laces caught in vicious vacuums?
Constantly fighting your garbage disposal
for your shoes?
Being hounded at school by shoe bandits?
You need Shoe Bands.
With our revolutionary technology, you'll
never worry about shoelaces getting untied
again.
Shoe Bands will make you more stylish, lose
ten pounds instantly, and will save baby penguins
from global warming.
Everybody loves them.
50 years of R and D, utilizing sic sigma,
lean production, and other buzzword processes,
went into the development of Shoe Bands.
Procured from pencil erasers, our rubber is
vulcanized twice to remove bad karma.
Here's what our customers have to say.
>> As an athlete, I need my shoes to stay
on.
Velcro provides some security, but to really
get the job done, I use my Shoe Bands.
>> Recently, one of our customers wrote in
to tell us about an experience where her Shoe
Bands saved her life. [screaming and growling]
Should have worn Shoe Bands.
>> Ever since I started using Shoe Bands,
I jacked up my bench press by 50 pounds.
Sometimes I even double-band. Sometimes I
double-band.
>> Hello, I'm the founder of Shoe Bands Incorporated.
But not only am I the CEO, I'm also an avid
and dedicated customer.
>> Through this exclusive TV offer receive
not two, but three packs of Shoe Bands, for
just five easy payments of 19.99.
Wait, call in the next sixty seconds and we'll
slash a payment and send you a llama. [baa]
That's right a llama [baa] Order today.
Exclusive shipping and handling.
Taxes may vary.
Consult your physician before handling llama.
And for more information visit our website
at www.ShoeBands.com.
>> Tina Seelig: Okay. I'm going to leave it
at that.
Pretty cool? Really funny. Anyways.
So again, the people did incredible things
with rubberbands.
And we were stunned by the creativity.
And one of the most interesting things is
this all happened outside the scope of a classroom.
Nobody told them what to do.
No one gave them a grade.
Nobody told them that it was due at a certain
time.
They took all their extra free time and put
all their creativity in doing this.
So I love the fact that we have all these
exercises that teach students how to turn
problems into opportunities, but there are
so many other things that go into being entrepreneurial.
And when I wrote this book about, What I wish
I knew when I was 20, one of the other key
concepts was how you make your own luck.
When I grew up, my father always used to say,
"The harder you work, the luckier you get.”
How many of you have ever heard that?
The harder I work, the luckier I get. Okay.
It's one of those things that's sort of drilled
into our heads.
But one of the most interesting things is,
I realized over the last years -- is that,
hard work is only the tip of the iceberg in
making yourself lucky.
There's so many things you can do to make
yourself lucky beyond just putting in a lot
hard work and sweat.
And I'm going to tell you a little story that
comes from my own life that brings this to
life.
Okay. So a few years ago, my son was about
this big.
He's now about this big.
And he and I were at the grocery store.
And I was at the grocery store with him.
We were sort of walking down one of the aisles
and a man came up to me.
And he asked me how to make a can of lemonade.
He had some lemonade can.
He said, "Excuse me, can you explain to me
how to make this lemonade?”
He was there with his daughter, who was about
the same size.
He had an accent.
He was clearly new to town, and I explained
to him how to make the lemonade.
You know, three cans of water to the can of
lemonade.
For most people, that would be the end of
the conversation, right?
He'd say, "Thank you very much," and you'd
go away.
But you know what?
I have learned from some of my wonderful colleagues
that, if you go somewhere and you don't meet
someone new, at the minimum, you've missed
out on the opportunity of learning something
or making a new friend.
At the maximum, you've missed out on the opportunity
of making a million dollars.
So I've really absorbed this attitude -- this
philosophy of life.
So when I was checking out of the grocery
store, I had a choice of different lines.
I got in line behind this guy.
Now, I was not stalking him, but you know,
I was just curious.
I wanted to learn a little bit more.
Maybe there was something I could do for him.
Maybe there's something he could do for me.
Maybe I'd learn something.
So I said, "Gee, you know, you have an interesting
accent.
Where are you from?”
He said, "I'm from Chile.
I'm from Santiago.”
And I said, "Oh, that's really interesting.
What are you doing here?”
At first, he was a little put off like, Why
am I asking these questions?
But he kind of melted and finally said, "Well,
I'm here.
I'm going to be taking over my family's business
in Chile, and I'm here for awhile to learn
about innovation and entrepreneurship." I
said, "That's so nice.
I actually run this program at Stanford that
focuses on entrepreneurship and high-tech
entrepreneurship.
If I can be helpful to you in any way, please
let me know.”
So I gave him my business card, and that was
the end of the conversation.
But he did contact me.
He sent me an e-mail.
He said, "You know, I'd really love to take
you up on your offer.”
So I introduced him to a few people and I
knew some folks from Chile and I knew some
venture capitalists who might be interested
in Latin America, and I helped him out.
He ended up bringing an entourage of people
to Stanford, including the president of the
Chile, and I helped out with that a little
bit.
That was the end.
He said, "Thank you very much." Went back
to Chile about a year, year and a half after
he had arrived.
A few years later, I was going down to Santiago
and I sent him an e-mail.
I said, "Eduardo, I'm going to be in Santiago.
Will you want to grab a cup of coffee?
I'd love to find out what's going on with
you.”
And he said, "Absolutely.”
But as the time came up, he was really too
busy.
And he said, "You know, Tina, I would love
to see you, but I just can't get away.
But do me a favor.
Come with a few of your colleagues and meet
at the lobby of this building in downtown
Santiago.”
So I said, "Sure.”
So I grabbed a few of my friends, and we went
over there.
We were met by one of his colleagues, who
took us to the roof of the building where
we were picked up by his family's helicopter,
flown over the city up to his family ski resort,
and then back down to the site of the city
where we left off.
And the moral of the story is that, you know,
most people stop at looking at life as turning
problems into opportunities -- that's like
turning lemons into lemonade.
But really entrepreneurship is about turning
lemonade into helicopters.
Pretty cool? Anyway, I thought that was kind
of a fun story, and it sort of had a fun punch
line.
But the fact is, you can make your own luck
in lots of different ways.
It's about being open, about being optimistic,
and about engaging the world in a way that
makes you pay attention to the opportunities
around you every single moment, as opposed
to being heads-down and staying in sort of
the rut you're in every single day.
You should look at the world as if you're
a foreign traveler, as if you're looking at
things for the first time and really, really
examining them.
So let's go onto another concept that I wrote
about in my book.
It is about failing fast and frequently. Okay?
I'm sure nobody here fails at Google, right?
Everything's always perfect?
But, you know, one of the secret sauces of
Silicon Valley is that you need to be able
to fail and fail gracefully.
In fact, it is known that probably the ratio
between your successes and your failures is
pretty constant.
If that ratio is constant then, if you want
more successes, you're going to have to put
up with more failures.
And the key is, you can't be so worried about
failure that you're not willing to try.
In fact, I have my students write "Failure
Resumes.”
Resumes with all their biggest screw-ups -- personal,
professional, and academic.
And the reason for this is that if you write
down your failures, and then what you learned
from it, that's when you really learn -- is
when you get to think back and say, "Boy,
I won't do that again.”
And in fact, it's funny.
When I wrote about this in my book and when
I showed an early draft to one of my students,
she said, "Boy, I was really interested in
this idea of 'failure resumes'.
I'd love to see what one looks like.”
So I said, "Okay.
We could do that.”
And I decided to put my own failure resume
in the book.
And I think I spent more time on those two
pages in the book than any other pages, because
it was a little bit nerve-wracking.
But it hasn't come back to bite me, and I
would encourage you to try it for yourself.
It is really quite an interesting process
to think about that.
And I want to show you here -- to amplify
this point.
I want to show you a video clip that came
from an innovation tournament.
Remember I told you about the rubberbands
and the paperclips? This was a clip -- I'm
going to show you -- from one of the teams
from the challenge with the rubberbands.
And this was a team that failed pretty miserably
-- and how they took that failure and turned
it into a success.
>> [guitar music]
>> [exciting music]
>> [singing] One more day down.
Everybody has those days, where one soft,
sweet song just enough to clear my head.
For hungry life.
Has anybody left their same?
>> Awesome thank you.
>> Slide on over and accept fate.
And there's a thousand feet of powerful things
here.
It's just that your week -- can we talk about
it?
It's getting so damn creepy just nursing this
ghost of chance -- fiction or romance -- and
accept color change, black and white people.
One boy headstrong.
It isn't going to hear just plain.
He's pushed down so hard you can hear him
start to sink.
One last round of petty conversation, "You
hold on boy, because you won't go down like
this.
You're just going to roll on over and lay
down.
How can you take.
It's just that you're weak.
Can we talk about it?
It's getting so damn creepy just nursing this
ghost of a chance -- the fiction or romance
-- the technicolor dream, called black and
white people.
Tina Seelig: Pretty cool?
I mean, they could have decided just not even
to submit this.
But they ended up winning one of the biggest
prizes, because they ended up really capturing
the essence of entrepreneurship.
It's about trying lots of things and keeping
what works.
And here is the coolest punch line of all.
This team was made up of the biodesign fellows
at Stanford.
These are students that come from medicine
and business and engineering.
And they spend a year shadowing doctors, identifying
the problems they had, coming up with inventions,
and eventually putting together a business
plan.
That team that did this, won the campuswide
business plan competition, competing against
hundreds of other business plans.
And of course, they never would have gotten
to that success if they hadn't embraced this
concept that they had to fail many times along
the way before coming up with something that
was a big success.
So I want to lead to a next topic, and that
is, "Don't wait to be anointed.” You know?
We often are in situations where we wait for
someone else to come and give us an assignment
-- to give us a job, to give us a role, to
give us a promotion.
But, you know, this is not what people who
are entrepreneurial do.
In any organization, in anywhere in life,
there are always problems to be solved.
There are always white spaces in the organization.
There are always ways that you can contribute
beyond what you even imagined.
And you don't have to wait for someone else
to give you those assignments.
Let me tell you a quick, little personal story
that amplifies this.
When I was a kid, my father became a very
successful, multinational corporate executive.
But he started out as an engineer. He was
an engineer.
And we got used to every couple years he'd
have another promotion, you know?
Turn director to a VP to executive vice PD
to executive senior blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
So this was something -- I was very proud
of him. He did very, very well.
But then, I decided to start my own company.
And I came to him and I'd made out business
cards, and they said, "Tina Seelig, President.”
And he looked at them and he looked at me,
and he got really mad.
He got annoyed with me.
He said, "How can you call yourself 'President'?
You can't just call yourself president.”
And I said, "Well, why not?”
He had grown up in this environment where
you have to wait for other people to anoint
you -- other people to give you that mantle
of power.
But entrepreneurs are those people who make
their own business cards.
They're the people who put the ladder below
them, as opposed to waiting for someone else
to put the ladder in front of them.
And the fact that this doesn't just happen
as an entrepreneurial, you know, attitude
in starting your own company, it's something
that happens here.
I mean, my goodness, Larry and Sergey are
not the only entrepreneurs at Google, right?
I mean, every single one of you are entrepreneurial,
solving problems along the way that come up.
And that's the point.
You don't have to wait for someone else to
give you permission to do something; you can
do it yourself.
And I want to play a videoclip here that came
again from the innovation tournament.
This is again, the ones with the rubberbands.
This is the team that captured the essence
of the fact that there is a very tiny switch
between doing nothing and doing something.
And it's really up to you whether you decide
to flip that switch and really make things
happen.
>> [piano music]
>> I worked out for the first time in weeks.
I ______ deeply with joy.
>> I finally took my chubby butt to the gym.
>> I carried a package for someone who was
overburdened.
>> I said, "thank you," more often.
>> I mustered up the courage to ask my crush
out.
>> I spoke with my dear friend on the phone
for an hour and a half.
I'm so glad to reconnect with her.
True friends are treasures in life.
>> Let me tell you about how these work.
These bands here -- they -- so we could try
to rally everyone behind one cause, but we're
not necessarily going to get people to agree
with us.
>> The "Do Band" is based on two insights
we had.
One, you can't force someone to agree with
your cause.
Without buy-in, nothing real is going to happen.
Two, everyone has their own cause, something
they should do, they want to do, but they
just never get to it.
And this is what we're after.
We want to get people over their block and
get them to do it.
Enter the Do Band.
>> The Do Band has a simple set of rules.
One, put it on with a promise and don't take
it off until you've fulfilled it.
Two, record your success online.
Share your story.
Three, pass it on.
>> Every Do Band comes with a serial number.
When you record your success, you can see
what else your band has inspired.
Each Do Band creates a chain of successes.
And that's just one Do Band.
With many Do Bands, it grows even quicker.
And with the addition of the virtual Do Band,
the numbers multiply astoundingly fast.
>> Do Bands that block by that comment.
>> What's happening with your Do Band?
>> Oh, I actually passed it off.
>> The Do Band creates value, by appealing
to our inner desires.
>> Done!
>> Just 36 hours, we created social value,
health value, entertainment value, and political
value, to name a few.
We may not have collected $500, but Do Bands
kicked off a new summer camp, initiated tons
of phone calls to mothers, inspired compliments
and apologies, healthy eating, and many other
personal contributions to the greater good.
These little things add up, and success is
infectious.
And one more thing, actually, people did donate
over $500 to the charities that they chose.
And this is only the beginning.
Imagine it.
>> [upbeat music]
Tina Seelig: Pretty cool? Great.
So the corollary to this is, Never miss an
opportunity to be fabulous.
Let me tell you the evolution of this phrase.
As I mentioned, I teach this course on creativity
and innovation.
And I never use slides in my class, because
it's all experiential.
I set up things, often things I've never done
before.
And I get the students to experiment with
all the variables related to creativity and
innovation.
But the first day of class, I do show some
slides to basically show them a roadmap of
what's going to come up ahead in the next
ten weeks.
And at the very bottom, the first day, you
know, the last slide, the last bullet point
is, "Never miss an opportunity to be fabulous.”
And I basically say, "I promise I'm going
to do my very, very best.
I'm going to give it my all teaching this
class.
And I expect the same from you.”
And the fact is, I would be happy to give
everyone in the class an A, but the bar is
very high, and I expect all of you to jump
over it.
This is different from most other classes,
right?
Most other classes, the teachers tell you
what you need to do to get an A.
I hate that question, right?
Will this be on the exam?
I look at my kid, who is a very, very sharp
kid.
He does -- and I'm sure many of you in this
room.
I won't ask you to raise your hand -- always
did the minimum amount to get an A.
Could you imagine what the world is like if
everyone does the minimum amount to get an
A?
The fact is, people who do amazing things
go well-beyond what it takes to get an A.
They're what's equivalent of an A plus, plus,
plus, plus, plus, plus.
The fascinating thing about this concept is
that it is incredibly sticky, because I believe
each of us is actually waiting for this instruction.
A few months after my class began a couple
years ago -- in fact, the story will date
itself in a minute.
You can tell me what year it was.
-- one of my students was sitting outside
when I got to class.
And she was listening to her iPod nano.
Now, I had never seen a nano before.
They were brand new.
And I said, "Hey, Becky, can I take a look
at that nano.
I haven't seen them before." She said, "Sure.”
She took it off, handed it to me, and apparently,
when you get it ordered online, you can have
it engraved on the back with something.
People usually have their e-mail address or
their phone number.
She turned it over, and on the back was engraved
with, what?
"Never miss an opportunity to be fabulous.”
That is what she wanted to look at every day.
And I think that's what most of us actually
really want to look at.
We want to say, "I have done the very best
I can.”
Because I think it's one of the reasons people
get frustrated in their lives is because they're
not challenging themselves.
They're not in a position where they really
are doing the very best they can.
So I want to leave with a videoclip.
This is actually the trailer for a movie.
What happened is -- remember I told you the
Kauffman foundation was excited about our
doing this innovation tournament, and we rolled
it out around the world the first year when
we did it with Post-it Notes?
Well, they had a professional video team that
was going to be capturing the week.
And the video team said, "Terrific.
This is what we want to capture the week is
this innovation tournament.”
So they put video crews around the world.
They were in Australia.
They were in Japan.
They were in Thailand.
They were in Ecuador.
They were in the United States.
They were in India.
Probably other countries I'm forgetting right
now.
This is -- they made a movie called, "Imagine
It.”
In fact, you can download the movie for free
at ImagineItProject.com.
But I'm going to show you the trailer for
the movie.
You'll recognize some of the cast of characters.
You'll recognize some of the stories.
And it was pretty terrific.
I captured the essence of what happened with
this around the world.
>> Imagine the future the way you'd like to
see it.
>> Because if you can imagine it, then it
can be.
>> Go to the problem, and imagine a world
where that problem has been removed.
And then say, "Well, how many steps are there
from this world to that world?"
>> Imagining a new future, a new path, a new
direction.
>> If you have the power to imagine it, you
have the power to change the world.
>> Imagine a more perfect world than the one
we live in, and then to actually engage in
making that happen.
>> [rock music] I believe I can fly.
I believe I can touch the sky.
I think about it every night and day.
Spread my wings and fly away.
I believe I can soar.
See me running through that open door.
I believe I can fly.
>> People think that pressure is bad, but
pressure -- in a very short period of time
-- can be stimulating.
>> It taps into the rawest level of their
creativity.
>> It puts down the gauntlet of challenge
and inspiration.
>> [music] Sometimes silence.
There are miracles in life...
>> You never have infinite resources.
And you're given this constraint.
And this constraint is Post-it pads.
>> We define the value of our project as innovating
outside of the box.
And the box here is actually a Post-it Note.
>> [music] I believe I can fly.
I believe I can touch the sky.
I think about it every night and day.
Spread my wings and fly away.
I believe I can soar.
See me going through that open door.
I believe I can fly.
>> A grand total of $3,200.
>> [music] I believe I can fly.
I believe I can fly.
Because I believe in you.
>> Entrepreneurship is an extreme sport.
Getting out and do it.
>> This is an important way to progress in
life.
>> It's an experiment in focus.
>> I bet you, you'll be blown away.
>> [music] I believe I can fly.
I believe I can touch the sky.
I think about it every night and day.
Spread my wings and fly away.
I believe I can soar.
See me running through that open door.
I believe I can fly.
>> Imagine It. Imagine It. Imagine It.
>> [Clapping] [cheering].
Tina Seelig: So hopefully, these exercises
demonstrate that we might be pushing these
kids off of this perfectly good cliff, but
also giving them a pretty good parachute so
that they feel actually comfortable when they
got out in the world -- taking on challenges,
taking risks, making things happen in ways
that they might have not been comfortable
with before this.
So I want to thank you very, very much.
And I'd be delighted to answer any questions.
>> [Clapping]
Tina Seelig: So any thoughts? Questions? Yeah.
>> [inaudible]
Tina Seelig: In my failure resume? Okay.
You got to bring that up. Let's see.
Most of the time, the failures on there were
failures that came from not really paying
attention to what was really going on and
making assumptions.
So like going in my first job after college,
going into a company and thinking I knew the
way things worked and acting based on the
way I thought it worked as opposed to to actually
taking the time to figure out the way it really
did work and then acting accordingly.
Or things where I didn't necessarily align
my goals with the goals of the other people
I was working with.
And you can easily do that.
All you have to do is actually pay attention
again to what the other people's goals are
and figuring out some ways to get them aligned.
Any other questions? No?
Well, if not, I'm happy to talk to anyone
afterwards.
Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]